uh our first talker for this lesson is
reuben mac who's a co-founder co-founder
of pi data and einho
and hogan he'll probably he'll connect
probably connect their pronunciation
and presented a couple times at
amsterdam trying to be bayesian
statistic casual causal and infer
inference
and deferential privacy working with his
amazing colleagues on cutting edge
technologies defining the future of the
advertising ecosystem
and since this is his time i'll let him
take over
you you have at well welcome everybody
and thanks for choosing my talk
and i honestly hope to raise some
awareness for attenuation bias during my
talk because i think it's a common
problem and is largely overlooked at the
moment
also
i'll explain to you a powerful but
simple trick that we use at greenhouse
to account for attenuation bias in geo
experiments
so before we kick off very brief
introduction about my company i joined
greenhouse 10 years ago and we're a
digital marketing agency inside the
netherlands
a couple of years ago we were acquired
by wpp and wpp is globally one of the
largest media communication company
holdings
so we've always had quite a substantial
data and technology department within
greenhouse
and
currently some of our technologies are
being used across the world within the
wpp network
so let's dive into our topic
before i explain attenuation bias i
would like to talk about the terminology
of bias itself
because i think it's used for many
things
also inside our field of expertise
so you might be thinking about something
like gender bias a model treating male
and female in a different way
well this definition is quite close to
the general definition and there's
something about ethics to it
but there are many other
things which we call bias which is a
little bit less obvious so maybe in
statistics we're discussing a biased
estimator which means that the
expectation of our estimator is
something different
than what we try to estimate
so of course this is a very different
meaning
it's maybe something you do not like but
there's not really an ethics part to it
and then for example in causal inference
confounding bias is you're measuring it
or you're calculating a correlation
rather than a causal effect
and there are quite a few of these kind
of biases like selectivity bias and
adaptivity bias
and then in the top right corner there's
a machine learning engineer and he's
thinking what's all the fuss about bias
i'm just talking about some parameter in
my weights and biases in my model but
obviously i'm not talking about this
last one
definition of bias because i truly think
it's not one out
so please allow me to give
my perspective on bias for this talk
which we i will use to explain
attenuation bias
so the perspective i'll use for the talk
is bias as being computing something
different than you intend to do and i'll
use this to explain what attenuation
bias is
so let's take this very simple example
of a linear regression
so what you aim to do
is to have an estimate for your beta
which is the effect or coefficient of
your the true x
however what might be happening in
reality is that you're not observing
your true x but a noisy x instead
so if you
for example apply ols
you're not computing beta hat as a
coefficient of your true x but of the
noisy x instead
and they'll show you now how this
creates bias in your results
but first be aware attenuation bias goes
by many names including measurement
error bias and regression dilution
so here's a simple example
of a linear regression but the only
difference having a sigma x is a one
here which is the same as sigma y which
we will be using
so if a true x
which is used in the calculation of y
however we also have our observed and
noisy x with added noise
of skill sigma x here and that's the
only one we can use in our regression
so let's see what the results look like
so here's the full results but what we
really
only want to look at is our confidence
interval for our estimate beta head
and as you can see the true beta 2.5 is
well outside of the complex interval and
this is not something that we want to
try
so this is us observing the attenuation
bias
so when you should you be aware of
potential attenuation bias
first of all there might be noise in
your observed x
but you care about what happens to why
when the true x changes
and what this says is that you're
actually doing inference not just plain
prediction or classification if you're
doing plane prediction or classification
then you do not need to worry about
potential attenuation bias
however in my experience many projects
that start off as a plain pure
prediction or classification project
turn out to be inference projects when
they are applied in business
and to explain why
i
conducted a very short story for you and
i hope you can recognize it from
preference
so in the story there's a manager and a
data scientist
and a manager is asking data scientists
to build a model to predict sales he's
very confident this will be super useful
the data scientist is asking how exactly
does the generate business value
at which the manager replies that he
doesn't know exactly but is really
confident that it will be valuable
so the data scientist goes to work
and two months later
she has finished her model she has this
amazing model that's predicting cells
with a super small prediction error at
which the manager replies awesome now
let's predict what happens when we
change the price to decide whether to
give a discount
and now certainly because of how the
model is being applied the problem
completely changed from a prediction
problem to an inference problem
and i think this happens quite often and
it's really important as a data
scientist or working in this field of
expertise that we do know whether we're
doing predicting
prediction or reundoing inference
because it really matters on how we
approach the problem
attenuation bias is one of the reasons
why it is important to know upfront what
you'll be doing
so of course it doesn't only apply to
the linear model in general if you care
about what happens to y when and through
exchanges
you need to think about potential
attenuation bias
and of course there's a very strong
connection to causal inference because
in causal inference we do not care about
what happens to why when the observed
exchanges but what happens when we
influence dx which can be something
completely different so from that
perspective we need to think about okay
maybe the observed x is noisy but what
we're influencing is not the noisy
observed x but it's the true underlying
x
so
why do i think attenuation bias is
overlooked
firstly because of all the great
breakthroughs in recent years in machine
learning a lot of focus has gone through
the prediction part of it
so i'm very happy to see that in the
more recent years that the cultural
influence got a lot of more attention
which is a good thing if you ask me
and second academia are conservative in
rejecting the null hypo hypothesis
and this one i should explain a little
bit more carefully
so there's something special about
attenuation bias because we do know the
direction of the bias it's always
towards zero so whether you have a
negative or a positive effect the effect
is always less strong if attenuation
bias occurs
so the result is that in academia
if there is a significant effect found
without accounting for attenuation bias
there will be a significant effect for
sure
however if we incorrectly account for
attenuation bias
we might be falsely rejecting the null
hypothesis and coming to a wrong
conclusion
so while this might make sense from an
academic perspective
in practice underestimation can be just
as costly as overestimation
and i'll show you with the example of
geo experiments later on in this talk
so how can we account for attenuation
bias
there's a family of traditional
solutions including the mean regression
orthogonal distance regression and total
least squares and i'll be showing you
our token of distance regression later
on
and then there's a new family called
error in variable models which includes
flexible bayesian methods
and they normally use latent variables
and there's some very recent work in how
you can apply these models in deep
learning
in this paper from may 2021
so this is great but in my experience
these error in variables models can be
quite sensitive to model specification
so what this means is that you might
still get biased results if you're
interested i have a repo here where i
show some examples that illustrate how
sensitive these models are and you might
still be getting biased results
[Music]
and then there's the proposed solution
of this talk
so it only works for binary treatment
but this is a very powerful and simple
trick
and i'm quite surprised that we have
been using it for quite some years and
i've never heard about anybody else's
using this trick so i hope it will be
helpful to you
so let's first give an example on how we
can solve the attenuation bias using
orthogonal distance regression so
there's no package to solve attenuation
bias in stats models which indicates
it's overlooked if you ask me
but side eye side by has the odr package
so
again we see that segment x is equal to
segment y here which equals one
and then we simply execute the
the regression
[Music]
so as you can see here
now we get unbiased results this is what
we want
but
be aware because we're making an
assumption here we assume that sigma x
is the same as sigma y and this is
important when you work with attenuation
bias
you need to know at least something
about sigma x and sigma y or the ratio
between the two of them
and i can show you in this example in
this example segment y is 0.1 and check
my x is equal to 1
and you can see below the bigger bias
results again
so how can you account for this in the
odr package
you can see here that you can simply
pair sigma x and sigma y into the model
or into your real data actually before
you estimate the model
and then we get the bias results again
so keep in mind you need to know
something about segment x or segment y
so on to our topic geo experiments
geo experiments are
done by doing an assignment of
treatments to different geographical
regions
there's an alternative to a b testing
well a b testing is maybe more powerful
and more common to do in some cases you
simply cannot conduct an a b test to
test some things
so
one of the reasons is that sometimes the
outcome cannot be measured in treated
and non-treated groups for example two
of my colleagues contributed to a paper
which studies the effectiveness of
mobile ads on store sales of course you
cannot measure whether somebody was in a
treated or non-treated group and
somebody's buying something inside a
store
the second reason is that in many cases
it's impossible to measure the
non-treated outcome for example in
google search ads so we are allowed to
do some measurements if we're showing an
ad to a user but we want to test against
not showing this ad and if we're not
showing an ad we are not allowed to make
these kind of measurements
so let's go a bit deeper in why exactly
do we want to experiments in google
search ads
so
in google search on behalf of our
advertisers we are placing bits to
become
have our ads or the companies at in the
top position of the search engine
so if people click on this ad
the advertiser base for the ad and the
user might go to the website and maybe
do a purchase
however not all of these purchases might
be truly causal
the reason for this is that if you would
not have been showing the ad here on top
the user might still be able to go to
and navigate to your website so one
thing could be that they use the organic
search results to navigate to your
website
and do the purchase
the other one could be that they use
to go directly to your website or maybe
through a bookmark
so not all of these sills coming out of
the clicks coming from these paid ads
might be causal but if we do an
experiment we do want to make sure that
we do not underestimate the effect if we
underestimate the effect our bits might
become too little
and we might not be shown on top and
users might not be able to find a
website or go to a competitor so this is
why
underestimation is just as bad as
overestimation
so
geo experiments what do they look like
there's a great paper by google
explaining how they can be done
in the united states there's something
called designated marketing areas and
those are often used to do these kind of
experiments in the netherlands we
normally use the provinces
to do this kind of experiments
then there's also a paper
by google in 2017
which discusses a slightly different
method it's also discussing orthogonal
regression but it's not really strongly
advising to do this kind of attenuation
correction
because they find the variance is really
high
so i don't completely agree with what
google's saying here because i think you
should always account for attenuation
bias in geo experiments or you'll be
underestimating your effectiveness
and with the
solution that i'll be showing you in
this talk it doesn't have to be hard to
do so
so a very simple example of what the
data looks like so in this example we
only have two time periods and two
geographical reasons regions so this is
in practice much too little data to
actually get the next estimate but for
clarity i'll show you what it looks like
so we have two time zones and two geo
locations
geographical areas here
and then in the first time period none
of them are being treated and in the
second period
only part of them are being treated
and this you can use to do a calculation
of the causal effect
but why exactly do we need to account
for attenuation bias in geo experiments
so of course we have the noisy x but why
is this x exactly noisy
so what we want to know is the effect of
the treatment which is showing s or not
showing ads
however what we observe is geo which is
a noisy mix for two reasons
one
different technologies are used for
estimating location and some of them are
noisy for example in google search
your phone might be using gps to do a
location estimate which is not always
super accurate
however if you go onto a website ip
address is used to give an approximate
geo location which is much more noisy
than that one and of course if you buy
something in a store you maybe have the
most accurate estimate
the second reason is
inside the experimental period people
move between treated and non-breeding
regions
so as a result those people are not
completely treated or non-treated but
something in between making a noisy x
however there is a good news also under
some assumptions we have data to
estimate sigma x so we can account for
this attenuation bias
so
our proposed solution
is a simple but powerful trick
and it only works for binary x
so if you think about a binary x
being noisy
you know
this is a bernoulli distribution
so the bernoulli distribution
has this property that the variance
is a function of b
of this parameter of your bernoulli
distribution p
so this also implies that if we know
sigma x we can compute p x for sure
and the solution is very simple just
use p x
instead of the binary x to run your
analysis
so what does this look like in the data
as an example so instead having a 0 and
a 1 for treatment
we get a 0.15 and 0.85
the inside here
so
0.5 is the bx for the non-treated while
you're doing the experiment and 0.85 is
the ph for the treated
during the experiment
so what's the intuition it's very easy
geos aren't fully treated not tweeted
but partly tweeted don't treat it and
the same thing can apply at the user
level
so
let's take our generic example and i can
show you how it works
so now instead of having a sigma x with
a px of 0.85
so what we do here
is that we apply noise according to dx
it's done here
and we again make x noisy and the noisy
x is what we can use in our regression
but the true x is what's actually being
used to construct our y
and you can see yes we have bias results
again
same thing when we have a binary x
and solving this problem is really easy
and straightforward you can just call
the function apply p
which is simply saying
if
it's treated then we
use px and otherwise one minus px
and then we use p to do a regression
it's a simple and powerful trick because
now we get unbiased results again
in fact
this solution is much better than
applying odr in this case
as we can see here
so
we can compute
sigma x
with the formula shown before out of our
p x here
and then again we pass sigma x and sigma
y to odr
but what happens is we get an
overestimation of a parameter
the reason this is the case is because
in ordinary linear regression it doesn't
matter when you have a binary variable
in your x
however
in this orthogonal distance regression
we assume that the noise inside of x is
normally distributed
and you can easily see if you look at
sigma x this is a standard deviation so
if you apply this to one and zero values
then you'll go well beyond and
below zero and above one
so that's why we have an overestimate
so in case of binary
x just use this trick don't use odr
so what are the application
so for us we apply this trick for
analysis of our geo experiments in fact
we don't do simple linear regression but
some more advanced bayesian analysis
second this can easily be applied to
double machine learning and other
methods for causal inference
also when you're imputing missing data
you should also be aware of attenuation
bias and the government suggests adding
noise to make computer data more
realistic however if the imputed
variable is used for inference if you
ask me you'll be introducing double
attenuation bias which leads to
underestimates of your effects
so for binaural variables you can just
impute bx instead
and last there's some recent work
about the use of machine learning
classification inside research which
these results are being used in
regression analysis of course this leads
to attenuation bias
in this working paper there are several
solutions being mentioned but not the
simple trick that i'm showing you in
this presentation so i hope this trick
can be useful to researchers also
so thanks a lot for your attention
so let's really recap the main takeaway
of this talk when should you be aware of
potential attenuation bias so there
might be noise in your observed x
we care about what happens to y when the
true exchanges
and you're doing inference not playing
prediction or classification
and as i shared with you before in my
experience many projects start off as a
prediction problem but when you apply
them to business they often become an
inference problem in that case you
should be aware
of potential attenuation bias
so there's some things i want to give
tobias klein a
professor who supervised mighty's mvs
jointly supervised many thesis students
afterwards concert was one of them and
he wrote his thesis about attenuation
bias in your experiments so a lot of
things to him also my two colleagues
manuzer bear and mark von zailer who
together with professor ernest ogen have
published a paper about the geo
experiments studying the effects of
mobile ads
on offline sales
and then of course google for publishing
the white papers on geo experiments
so thanks a lot for your attention are
there any questions
all right come in
how do you
what do you think about estimating
t
of x for odr
um i'm not 100 sure but i understand the
question correctly but the the main
thing is if you know your p x
then you don't need to do odr right it's
really an alternative to doing odr
all right another one
if there is time if you could elaborate
again how attenuation bias and cat
causality are related i did not fully
understand that part
yeah
so
um here's the intuition at least if you
are thinking about causal inference so
um you're thinking about okay
you can think about the do operator so
what exactly will i be changing or what
will i be influencing
um
in inside my x and that's your causal
effect right your causal effect is okay
what happens to y if i change my x which
can be different from the observed
changes in x
so
the relationship is that i think it's a
very good framework
this causal inference framework to also
think about attenuation bias
so it might be the case that
you're observing a noisy ex
but uh you are influencing the two x
that's underlying so let's it's a little
bit of an abstract example but let's say
you have a noisy x and you know for sure
that you can do plus five on this noisy
x and the difference will always be plus
five then in fact you're influencing the
noisy x and not the underlying true x
but i think in many cases it won't be
like that so if you do
treatment or interception you'll be
influencing the
true x and you only can measure
the noisy version of x
another thing that might happen is that
you might have a noisy x but once you
start influencing the noisy x you will
be able to actually measure the true x
instead of the noisy x this is a
slightly different topic because
well then you need to think about it in
a different way it might actually be the
case that if you only use
the data after
doing the intervention you don't have a
noisy x anymore in general you also need
to account for it if the amount of noise
in x changes but that's a little bit of
a different topic
i hope that answered the question
or at least a little bit the intuition
behind it oh yeah
thank you very much those are very
interest interesting sort of like
getting into different
different worlds you generally these
days you hear about like
you know like bias it's sort of these
like grand
ones
like
like and like social aspects and then
we get in drill down deeper into
different aspects of that
anyways
thank you very much i was definitely
very ha
glad to be able to moderate for you i
like yes i hope you enjoy the rest of
the conference and
you know the week in general
all right thank you thanks for uh for
hosting
yeah you have a wonderful day
you too